first my colleague from Vermont Bernie
Sanders thank you money and I want to
congratulate you for your continued
leadership in this area um I get around
the state of Vermont a whole lot and I
talked to many people all over the
country and what people are saying to me
is that in this country the richest
country in the history of the world
there is something very wrong that 43
million Americans have no health
insurance at all and millions more are
under insured and as Barney Frank just
indicated it makes no sense at all to be
talking about putting another hundred
and ten billion into the military as the
president would like or even worse a
hundred and forty plus into the defense
as the Republicans want when millions of
people have no health insurance millions
of more have inadequate health insurance
and tens of millions are unable to
afford the prescription drugs that they
desperately need it it makes no sense to
me to be spending a hundred billion
dollars a year defending Europe and Asia
against non-existent enemies when in
this country we have by far the highest
rate of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world when we have over
twenty percent of our kids living in
poverty when senior citizens all over
this country cannot afford basic needs
by keeping their homes warm or paying
for their out-of-pocket health care that
they need the two basic issues are
number one given the end of the Cold War
given the collapse of the Soviet Union
does any sensible person really believe
that we need to spend billions and
billions
more on the military there's any
sensible person believe that our
military posture should be to
simultaneously be fighting two wars
without any allies to protect us despite
all of the money that NATO spends and I
think the obvious answer is no there is
enormous waste in the military right now
we all know that we all know that pork
is rampant where various districts get
money for the military that is not
needed so the truth of the matter is we
can have the strongest defense in the
world we can raise the pay and the
benefits that our military does need but
you don't have to spend more money on
the defense or the CIA or the
intelligence budget to do that but the
most important point that I want to make
is that we have got to get our
priorities straight we cannot continue
to cut back on Medicare we cannot
continue to have Medicaid paying in my
state about one-third of the normal
reimbursements that physicians and
hospitals get we cannot continue to have
millions of people spending fifty sixty
percent of their limited incomes on
housing at the same time as we cut back
on affordable housing in this great
country what we have got to do is make
sure that all of our people have a
decent standard of living not continuing
to cut cut and cut on the needs of
working families senior citizens
veterans low-income people and then say
to the military hey we can give you
everything you need and and then some
more so I think for those of us who
believe in insane priorities in this
country but those of us who believe that
every American is entitled to a decent
standard of living we have got to stand
up and oppose this outrageous proposal
to increase military spending thank you
very much